well first of all you have an amazing
blog that people should check out but
you also have this in that blog a set of
predictions
it's such a cool idea i don't know how
long ago you started like three four
years ago it was um january 1st 2018
18.
yeah and i made these predictions and i
said that every january 1st i was going
to check back on how my predictions had
been that's that's right for 32 years
oh you said 32 years i said 32 years
because it's still that'll be january
1st 2015 yeah i'll be
i will just turn 95
um
right
you know so
uh and so people know that your
predictions at least for now are in the
space of artificial intelligence yeah i
didn't say i was going to make new
predictions i was just going to measure
this set of predictions that i made
because yeah it was sort of i was sort
of annoyed that everyone could make
predictions they didn't come true and
everyone forgot so i should hold myself
to a high standard yeah but also just
putting years and like date rangers on
things it's a good thought exercise yeah
like and like reasoning your thoughts
out and so the topics are
artificial intelligence autonomous
vehicles and space yeah
um
i was wondering if we could just go
through some that stand out maybe from
memory i can just mention to you some
let's talk about self-driving cars like
some predictions that you're
particularly proud of or are
particularly interesting
uh from flying cars
to
the other element here is
like how widespread the location
where the deployment of the autonomous
vehicles is
and there's also just a few fun ones is
there something that jumps to mind that
you remember from the predictions
well i think i did put in there that
there would be a
dedicated self-driving lane on 101 by
some year and i think i was over
optimistic on that one
yeah actually yeah i actually do
remember that but you uh i think you
were mentioning like difficulties in
different cities yeah
so
cambridge massachusetts i think was an
example yeah like in cambridge port you
know yeah i lived in cambridgeport for a
number of years and
you know the roads are narrow and
getting getting anywhere as a human
driver is incredibly frustrating when
you start to put and and people drive
the wrong way on one-way streets there
it's just
so your prediction was
driverless taxi services operating on
all streets in cambridgeport
massachusetts
in uh
2035.
yeah and
that may have been too optimistic you
think so you know i've gotten a little
more pessimistic since i made these
internally on some of these things so
what
uh
can you put a year to a major milestone
of deployment of a taxi service
in um
in a few major cities like something
where you feel like yeah so autonomous
vehicles
so let's let's take um
the grid streets of san francisco north
of market
okay okay
um
relatively benign um
uh environment the streets are wide
um
the major
problem is
delivery trucks stopping everywhere
which made things more complicated
um a taxi system there with
um
somewhat designated pickup and drop-offs
unlike with uber and lyft where you can
sort of get to any place and the drivers
will figure out how to
get in there um
we're still a few years away i you know
i live in that area so i see
you know the self-driving car companies
cars
multiple multiple ones every day outside
cruise
zooks less often
way more all the time
different and different ones come and go
and there's always a driver
there's always a driver at the moment
although i have noticed
that um
sometimes the driver does not have the
authority to take over without talking
to the home office because they will sit
there waiting for a long time
and clearly something's going on where
the home office is making a decision um
so they're you know and
and so you can
see whether they've got their hands on
the wheel or not and
and it's the incident resolution time
that tells you gives you some clues
so what year do you think what's your
intuition what date range are you
currently thinking
san francisco would be
autonomous uh
taxi service from any point a to any
point b without a driver
are you are you still
are you thinking uh 10 years from now 20
years from now 30 years from now
certainly not 10 years from now
it's going to be longer if you're
allowed to go south of market way longer
um
and unless it's re-engineering of course
roads
by the way what's the biggest challenge
you can mention a few is it the the is
it the delivery trucks is it the edge
cases the computer perception
uh
here's a case that i saw outside my
house a few weeks ago
um about 8 pm on a friday night it was
getting dark it was before the solstice
um
it was a
cruise vehicle come down the hill uh
turned right
um
and
stopped dead
covering the crosswalk why didn't it
stop dead because there was a
human just two feet from it
now i just glanced i knew what was
happening the human
was
a woman was at the door of her car
trying to unlock it with one of those
things that yeah you know when you don't
have a key yes
that car
thought
oh she could jump out in front of me any
second yeah as a human i could tell no
she's not gonna jump out she's busy
trying to unlock her she's lost her keys
she's trying to get in the car
and it it stayed there for
until i got bored um yeah
and so the human driver in there did not
take over
but here's the kicker to me
a guy comes down the hill with a
stroller i assume there's a baby in
there
and
now the crosswalk's blocked by this
cruise vehicle
what's he gonna do
cleverly i think he decided not to go in
front of the car
he went but he had to go behind it he
had to get off the crosswalk out into
the intersection
to push his baby around this car which
was stopped there and no human driver
would have stopped there for that length
of time
um they would have gotten out of the way
and that's another one of my
pet peeves
that
safety has been compromised
for individuals who didn't sign up for
having this happen in their
neighborhood
yeah but
now you can say that's an age case but
yeah well i'm in general
not a fan which
uh of uh anecdotal evidence for stuff
like this is one of my biggest problems
with the discussion of autonomous
vehicles in general people that
criticize them or support them by using
cases okay uh aren't using anything so
so let me let me but i got you you know
you know your question is when is it
going to happen in san francisco i say
not soon but now it's going to be one of
them but when where it is going to
happen
is in
um
uh limited domains
uh campuses of various sorts
gated communities
where the other drivers
are
are not arbitrary people um they're
people who know about these things they
you know it's been warned about them
and at velocities where it's always safe
to stop dead yeah um you can't do that
on the freeway that i think we're gonna
start to see
um
and they may not be shaped like
you know current cars and maybe you know
things like you know may mobility has
those
things and various companies have these
yeah i wonder if that's a compelling
experience to me it's always important
it's not just about automation it's
about creating a product that like
that makes your it's not just cheaper
but makes your this fun to ride uh one
of the most one of the least fun things
is for a car that stops
and like waits there's something deeply
frustrating for us humans
for the rest of the world to take
advantage of us as we wait but
um
think about uh you know not you as the
customer but someone who's in their
80s
in an uh you know a retirement village
whose kids have said you're not driving
anymore and this gives you the freedom
to go to the market more that's a hugely
beneficial thing but
it's a very uh few orders of magnitude
less impact on the world it's not it's
just a few people in a small community
using cars as opposed to the entirety of
the world
uh
i like that uh the first time that a car
equipped with some version of a solution
to the trolley problem is uh what's niml
stand for like not in my life not in my
life i define my lifetime as up 2050
2015.
yeah
uh you know and then i ask i ask you
when when have you had to decide which
person should i kill um no you put the
brakes on and you break as hard as you
can
it is uh you know i do think autonomous
vehicles or semi-autonomous vehicles do
need to solve the whole pedestrian
problem that has elements of the trolley
problem within it but it's not yeah well
so here's a and i talk about it in one
of the articles or blog posts that i
wrote his his and people have told me
one of my co-workers has told me he does
this
he
he tortures
autonomously driven vehicles and
pedestrians will torture them they'll
you know once they realize that you know
putting one foot off the curb makes the
car think that they might walk into the
road kids teenagers will be doing that
all the time they will
i by the way one of my that's a whole
nother discussion because my main issue
with robotics is hri human robot
interaction
i believe that robots that interact with
humans will have to uh push back
like they can't just be
bullied because that creates a very
uncompelling experience for the humans
yeah well you know waymo before it was
called waymo discovered that you know
they had to do that at four-way
intersections they had to they had to
nudge forward to give the cue that they
were going to go because otherwise the
other drivers would just
beat them all the time
you